undefeated Floyd Mayweather versus the  legendary Manny Pacquiao this is the  kind of showdown blockbuster movies are  made of so just in case you missed it  here in a supercut of the absolute  greatest moments from Mayweather vs.  Pacquiao let the fight begin  place finisher mm attendance Dancing  with the Stars  manney budget  Manny Pacquiao may appear to be a white  woman with a fake go team manny season  yard he doesn't speak Spanish he's from  the Philippines okay okay now when you  hear the bell let's have a fight  damn dude stop doing stop  and the winner is Mayweather wait what  and achieve you I did I mean can anyone  really be surprised Mayweather is  undefeated don't forget to subscribe to  new media rockstars for more amazing  super cuts of amazing things that you  care about so comment with who you think  should go up against Mayweather next  I'm drew Coolidge and I will fight  anybody anytime ah